hi there today we're taking a look at
get in especially get as it is used
maybe in research collaborations so it
is like a tool to collaborate but when
we do research like when you work on a
paper together with other people you
won't use a lot of the features that get
offers and that are usually described by
git so in this series I want to talk
about how was kind of the most simple
way to collaborate with people on like a
research project using it and today
we're gonna go over just the
fundamentals and which makes everything
else a lot easier so what do you need to
understand about git is that
fundamentally git is a graph and it's a
graph of commits what I mean by this so
let's say you have your paper you write
some things and then this is kind of
version 1 and then you have another
paper or the same paper and you kind of
changed this line here that's version 2
and so on you have kind of this chain of
versions that you would like to keep in
store this so this is that the classic
example of version control where you
would like to save these versions and do
it in a way that you can at any point in
time go back to any version previously
and this is exactly what git does
without you having to kind of rename
like people usually copy the file and
then rename like this version 2 version
3 final version really final version
really final version corrected bubble
all right so get fundamentally is a
graph and a graph of an object we call a
commit so commit which I'm going to
represent as a bubble here is simply a
kind of an image of your hard drive or
one folder of your hard drive at a
particular point in time so this will
contain all kind of files let's call
this file a file the oops well meant to
make a square here but all the files
in your folder which is the call to git
repository
or it's not correct but bear with me you
have this folder and all the files in
this folder when you make a commit all
these files are kind of saved as they
are into one of these bubbles and
they're saved forever basically in this
in this status that there so what you
can do now is you can go ahead and make
a second commit so you change a bunch of
files let's say the file B is still the
same and but the file a has changed is
not a prime you make a second commit and
the second commit references the first
commit so part of a commit except the
very first commit part of a commit is
always a pointer to its parent commit
and especially if you look at the
commits they all have names and the name
of a commit is always its hash and the
hash includes basically the hash of all
the files that are in there so a hash
could be something like f5c two five
nine and so on and for the next commit
the hash also includes the reference to
the parent that's why that the integral
part of a commit is to which parent it
belongs this ultimately is what makes
the graph kind of the graph I recommend
and her references it's parent so you
can address every commit by its name as
I said which is the hash of the commit
and you can also so the hash is like
really long but you can also simply
reference it by kind of the first couple
of letters as long as that's unique it
will let you do this whenever you need
to reference some commit all right so
we've discussed that basically a commit
is a bunch of files as they are and it
saved in this state so gates of course
smart it will only kind of save the diff
from one to the other
but um you can just imagine that a
commit to simply want the status of a
formal rather particular point in time
so let me just take away these files
here there are a bunch of other things
in in git
so the kind of um one concept that gate
has is called the tag a tag is a name
for a commit that you give yourself and
the tag is like a little flag that
sticks in a commit and you may say this
V one version one this is simply a tag
and as you make new commits and so on
the tag simply states earned at any time
if you don't want to remember this big
long hash you can simply refer to this
commit as v1 because that's the tag
that's kind of simple the next form of a
little flag that you can append to
commit is called a branch and a branch
the difference between the tag and a
branch so branches also is and we'll
call it
I don't know blah the difference is that
when you are on this commit here right
here and you make a commit on top of
this commit while what's called you've
checked out the bla branch so right now
you're looking at blah which is this
commit and you make a commit on top of
this commit what kit will do
automatically for you is it'll erase
this flag and move it to this next
commit bla so this is kind of so you
might know branch is kind of from
subversion or other version control
technologies it's very similar but in
get a branch is simply like a tag it's
simply a name for a commit but with the
additional property that when you make a
commit on top of that commit so when it
when it has the commit that is its
parent then it will move the the branch
the little flag to the new commit so
basically
you always have that one branch which is
called master it creates this
automatically for you if you just have
this is a little flag master right and
you make it commit on top of master
which would cause master to go here
master and so on so people usually say
they work on the master branch which
means they're simply making commits on
top of the commit that currently has the
master flag it also allows you to move
around both tags and these little the
branches basically to any comment so I
could forcefully go erase this here and
gently stick the master flag here and
sometimes if we kind of if we kind of
decide these two commits are no good we
would simply do this we would simply
take the master flag put it here and
then we when we make it new commit on
top of the master now what we would make
is we make a new commit point here then
it would move the master flag because
it's a branch master and then we simply
continue working here working here and
get will happily move along this master
so in get there is no need to actually
delete commits or something like this
what we can simply do is um is kind of
move the move the branch that we're
working on to the commit we like and
garbage collection ultimately will at
some point go and delete these two
commits this is a bit more difficult
once you collaborate with other people
because they might actually have made
commits that reference the commits that
you you just kind of deleted or so so
that's a bit tricky but ultimately this
is something you can do so the next
thing we're going to talk about is
multiple branches having multiple
branches basically falls down to you
have
Fuca minutes you have your graph and
let's say this is your master branch so
here we have master but also or let's
make the one before otherwise I don't
have space master
so what someone else would like to do
like is say hey I want to like try out
this new feature in code it will
probably change the code base and so on
but I'm going to try it out
maybe it'll introduce some bugs and so
on and then what you can do is you can
make a new branch F one that's called f1
for feature one so and then you can I
can make a commit on top of feature one
which will then move the feature one
flag to here and so on I can make second
and third commit and so on meanwhile the
other people working on the project or
maybe even you yourself can work on top
of this commit of top of the master
branch so in in kind of software
engineering this is typically used when
one part of the team wants to implement
a new feature but the other part of the
team kind of continues to do bug fixes
or things like this and development on
the version of the software that doesn't
yet have the new feature but they kind
of need to fix bugs and since the new
feature is not complete yet they can't
both work on the same code base so each
work on on their own branch so to say
and at the end when the feature one kind
of is ready that people say like ok
we've implemented it it's all good
there's no bugs we would like to
integrate the feature one into the the
main software basically what you have to
do is you would have to do a so called
merge
a merge is a process that generates a
merge commit and a merge commit is this
thing here as you know this is has more
than one parent it has in this case two
parents where the kind of combines so
from this commits here both branches are
based off of this commit and then
changes were made individual changes in
this branch and in this branch so
there's the possibility that you know
people change different things and what
the merge commit needs to do somehow is
to bring together these changes so
actually both branches might have
changed the same file but in a different
way and now the question is how do we
merge these different files and that's
kind of the the last topic we're going
to today how does get to a merge so when
when you talk about merging gift has a
bunch of built-in algorithms that it
helps you with most of the time merging
is automatic so if you have like files
here a and B and one in one branch a is
changed some here and in one branch B
has changed it simply as soon as well
this one branch has changed a the other
one hasn't so the changes you know they
mean something
I'll take them and as well and B so get
basically whenever something has changed
in one branch and not changed in the
other it will it will assume that that
changes or the thing that needs to
continue to live basically it assumes
that the changes were made for a reason
and that reason should you know continue
so one might be a bug fix the other one
might be the new feature this
same goes in the same file so when you
have the same file and one branch in one
branch something on top is changed and
the other branch something kind of on
the bottom has changed it simply assumes
both changes are wanted and takes takes
both the only kind of time when git
doesn't know what to do is when both
branches change the same line so
represent this with I don't know but
when both branches change the same line
in the same file kind of or close close
by so there are these algorithms that
keep determines when there's a so called
merge conflict that's the only time work
it doesn't know what to do
and so as preliminary it's a good idea
to structure files in a line based
fashion especially if you write kind of
latte
a good practice is to put every sentence
on a new line and not have like giant
lines of you know multiple sentences
because if you put every sentence on a
new line then you immediately kind of
see where something was changed whereas
if you have this big paragraph and it
will simply tell you this line has
changed which is an entire paragraph and
you don't see what's what's happening so
when you have a merge conflict it asks
you what to do and it does this in a
very simple way we're just gonna kind of
take a look here as a final
demonstration so I have a git repository
here let me that so as you can see
there's simply this test a file in here
and I've just made one commit to the
initial commit and let's look at this
test file it simply says hello so what I
can do is for example I can say hi I can
when I want to make a new commit first
of all get status will always tell you
kind of what you can do what's happening
in your
posit Ori here it says change is not
staged for commit modified test dot txt
and it also tells you what you can do so
it tells me for example use get checkout
- - with the filename to discard changes
or use get add to update what will be
committed there's a I'll use get add
with this so it tells me changes to be
committed now it's green as you can see
so when I now type git commit it should
commit these changes and this is common
occurrence and yet whenever you see a
text editor opening it expects you to
type a text message like a commit
message in this case that it like a log
message basically um that hashtags are
comments which will not go in here this
is all is all described right here
actually in these comments the thing
about these things is it when you type
an empty message then gate will abort to
commit so it's if you notice you've done
something wrong you can simply save this
file with them being empty being nothing
but commit comments basically gate will
abort so it's super useful I'll just say
added hi and then save this file so this
is not a special thing all you need to
do this is an editor a text editor that
edits a text file you simply need to
save the file and close the editor and
get will be like okay cool I'll continue
so with git log now you can see we have
two comments we have my initial commit
and we have to commit called added hi if
you look at the test file you see hi so
what we'll do now is finally we'll make
two branches as I as we discussed before
so this is my initial commit I've made
one more commit and we're on branch
master right now which get status will
tell you
on branch master so this is now master
what we'll do is we'll make a new branch
called f1 we'll make a commit on f1
meaning we'll move this f1 then we'll
make a commit on top of master like this
with which meaning we'll move this
master and then we will merge f1 back
into master such that kind of this
master is here and at the end we can
even kind of remove the f1 branch and
we'll do this while we're having a merge
conflict so that you see the whole
process so okay so what I want to do is
first I want to make a branch f1 for
this we can use check out - B for making
a new branch f1 if the branch already
exists you simply need to check out
which means I simply go to where this
branch is - the commit that the branch
references to we also say we put head
where to D to this commit head is always
the thing you're looking at basically
the thing you've currently checked out
so make a new branch f1 and will
immediately switch to f1 if I type
status it says on branch f1 it's still
the same commit but we're just in a
different branch so we'll make kind of a
change to this file here I'm gonna say
hello cool save the file status it says
it's modified I want to add and commit
it and there's a shortcut commit - a - M
so the ape simply says all the files
that have changed
I had them so I don't need to add git
add all the changed files separately
though this only counts for kind of
changed files if you have completely new
files that get isn't tracking yet you
need to add them yourself
but so here with a - a I skip the need
to first add the vows and with the - em
I can give directly the commit message
more oh cool so now what we've done is
where we have made this commit here and
move to the f1 flag to this commit what
we'll do now is we'll go back to this
commit which is currently master branch
and we'll make this commit so first what
we need to do is we'll go back to some
commit which is a check out check out
master since master is still referring
to that commit as you can see when I
open the test file
there's no hello it's the status from
before hello I can now say I cannot
change the file in some other manner in
this case I say hello because I want
many E's and I can say I can commit this
because I'm now on the branch master it
will make this new commit here and move
the master branch to that more II if you
look at git log you see all these
commits on this kind of branch you don't
see the commits on the f1 branch for
that I wouldn't have to go back f2 the
f1 branch I log and you see here it's a
different story
after the added high commit there's the
more o commit whereas up here after that
at high commit there's the more e commit
so merging and by the way merging also
is not only happens when you have
different branches but also because it's
the same thing when you collaborate with
other people and these people make
commits and you make commits independent
of each other and you kind of try to
synchronize your work often you need to
do a merge and then emerge conflicts can
also happen so what we do now is we come
back to
master because we yeah check out master
they're like shortcuts for all of these
but so we're on this branch right here
and we want it what we're going to do is
we want to make the merge commit and so
we want to merge f1 into master so while
I am on master I can say git merge f1
and it will try to merge but it will
tell me conflict automatic merge failed
fix conflicts and then commit the result
I can say git status and it will tell me
you're currently merging you have
unmerged paths and this test or txt file
is both branches modified it so I'm
going to the test and this is very
strange if you see for the first time
but it's actually very intuitive so what
it will do is wherever the line is that
both branches have changed or whatever
that the block of lines is that both
branches have changed it will basically
indicate this with by writing directly
into the file so it'll make these
smaller smaller smaller smaller smaller
than sign and then it says head which
means this is the the thing you're
currently looking at which we know it's
master has changed this first line to
this helo then it will be like equal
equal equal equal and then it will say
down here we'll say the f1 branch has
changed this line the same line to hell
and it will able to notice with like the
end of this with like bit larger larger
larger larger greater than signs so what
you need to do to in order to emerge is
simply you need to make this file as you
wish it is in the merged State first of
all you can always start by kind of
removing actually a good practice may be
to remove these equal lines and then
within this delimiter is kind of change
what you how you want the file to look
in essence I simply want to have these
OHS here at at the end there's one too
many like this or like this I like that
so I'm gonna call that the murse and
then I delete these lines so this is the
file that I would like the two the
merged commit to have so what I can do I
save this file again I say git status it
still tells me it's unmerged but it
tells me what to do it says use git add
to mark resolution all right
I've resolved it git add test.txt
git status and it says all conflicts
fixed but you are still merging use git
commit to conclude merge all right get
commit damn and I'm still I'm still have
to enter a commit message which is
already predefined here saying I merged
the branch f1 and there's conflict there
were conflicts but that's fine I like
this message so I'm simply gonna save
the file right here and when I'm looking
to get log it now gives me the full
story first I have this added high
commit then I have the more committed
the more II committed which were in
parallel to each other and then I merged
both branches into one so we're now
right here what I can do now is I can
even delete the f1 flag because I don't
need it anymore basically which I do by
gate Brown
- the f1 and it has deleted branch f1 so
no commits are actually deleted when you
delete the branch it's it simply the
little flag is deleted the only danger
is when you delete the little flat and
the name and you're unable to reach the
commit
from any other name but here of course
we have this master and by following
this edge here we can reach this commit
just fine so get won't delete it all
right or garbage collected but it will
also tell you when you're about to do
something dangerous so don't worry all
right
so with this I think you should already
have many tools or many many insights
into get and another video we're going
to look at how to collaborate online
with people which isn't much harder than
this it's it's simply like two more
steps to do to push and pull your work
from a server together with other people
alright so that was it take care